yvonne farrell and shelly mcnamara
co-founded grafton architects in 1978
four years after they had graduated from
the University College in Dublin and two
years after they began their
spectacularly influential careers as
teachers at university college as well
since then at the academia de
arquitectura in Madrasi oh and the Ecole
Polytechnique fédérale Amazon and in
2010 at Harvard where they were the
Kenzo tandy chair they shared the chair
at Harvard at the Graduate School of
Design in 2009 they lectured in our
school now it's our pleasure in
welcoming them back to Yale as Lewis
icon visiting professors established
through the generosity of friends of
admirers of leucon to honor the memory
of a great architect and teacher who was
for 10 years senior critic at this
school and who designed two major
buildings at Yale the professorship
enables us to invite distinguished
architects to teach in the design studio
since 1999 the following architects have
held a con for fessor ship sometimes
multiple times and you leave the skin
Todd Williams and Billie Tsien demetri
porphyrios Peter Eisenman and Frank
Gehry Grafton architects came to
international prominence in 2008 when
their Bocconi University building in
Milan was the winner of the world the
building of the Year award in 2002
Grafton architects were the first Irish
practice invited to show in the Italian
Pavilion that's an interesting
confluence shall we say as part of the
Venice Biennale their work was also
exhibited at the 2008 billion Olli in
the Irish group exhibit the lives of
spaces the practice is successfully
participated in a number of
national competitions in 2010 their
design was selected for the new
headquarters of the electricity supply
board in Dublin and recently their
proposal for the new School of Economics
for the University of Toulouse and
France was selected the work of Grafton
architects stands apart from the noise
of contemporary practice rooted in
programmatic responsibility and in
building craft it consists of buildings
that are bold in character and subtle in
detail please join me in welcoming
newest icon visiting professors Yvonne
Farrell and Shelley McNamara as they
deliver tonight's lecture architecture
as the new geography good evening I
would like to say how honored Shelley
and I are to be the Lewis icon visiting
professors here in Yale we would like to
thank Dean Stern for his kind invitation
we look forward to working with our
assistant Martin Cox and our students
during this semester it's been as the
Dean has said two years since we have
spoken here in Yale this evening we wish
to show samples of our work some of
which you may know from before as well
as new work we use our built work as a
method of tracking the making of space
in order for us to continue to assess
and reevaluate we go back as well as
move forward when we see images of
cities destroyed we realize how
buildings hold culture and civilization
buildings are the mirrors of our values
they tell the story of our lives in
built form with globalization
architectures role to hold culture is
even more critical than before we feel
places we feel places with our whole
bodies and
with all our senses not just our eyes or
our minds we as humans are fully
involved in the experience it is in fact
what makes us human
buildings actually envelop us doing so
over time each day throughout all the
seasons architecture is a shield and a
protector of our humanity as more and
more of the natural world disappears
what we do as architects in making this
new landscape of buildings has deep
societal repercussions this is why we
use the term this evening architecture
the new geography starting we'd like to
I suppose focus on three main projects
this evening one in Dublin one in Milan
and one in Toulouse but we'd like to I
suppose by way of introduction give you
some idea of things in the air things
were interested in things we argue about
things we worry about and this first
image is a photograph we took when we
look when to look at the site for the
competition in in Toulouse and
it we just captured managed to capture
the child in the spotlight of the
sunlight and David leather borough
delivered a lecture in Dublin recently
called shadows society and in some ways
some of the things he said articulated
things we had been thinking about where
he talked about the modulation of light
and temperature at architectural edges
has social significance the mixing of
light and darkness at the meeting points
of streets and interiors sets the stage
for various enactments of public life
and we were intrigued by this by this
statement because we we often talk about
what kind of presence a building needs
to have on a site on a street in a city
and what how can it act as the kind of
backdrop
for the the public life that is that it
facilitates and perhaps rather than
thinking about elevations and image and
language and all these these terms that
we normally use that if we think about
about that threshold between inside and
outside between light and shade that
somehow it's it's very challenging this
is the rock of cashel in the middle of
Ireland monumental outcrop of
architecture and landscape merged and in
a way this represents the other
discussion which we often have which is
this idea of weight and mass in
contemporary architecture and with
weight and mass comes ideas of gravity
and connection and we love phrase quote
by Fernando tavarov where he says when
we use the word gravity we evoke both
the notion of weight and of intelligent
and thoughtful action let us not forget
gravity physical or plastic contributes
to the temporal or symbolic stability of
architecture but of course we're also
interested in defying gravity in
stretching structure and and and pushing
structure to its limits
and this image of the skeleton of the
Lina Bo Bardi Museum of Contemporary Art
in Sao Paulo in some way represents this
where she made this 80 meter span making
the structure feel like it's hovering
over the city making at Belvedere a
public space beneath or these bridges
the under craft of this confluence of
two bridges in Toulouse but somehow
describe the sense of presence produced
by mass bearing down and being borne up
that ancient sense of moving amidst the
play of the forces of gravity and this
drawing which we loved from Italian
thoughts by the Smiths ins where they
talk about conglomerate ordering and
where they express so well the the
blurring of lines between landscape and
building
between object and and and landscape and
we we work a lot with surface and the
the making of layers of surface as both
always looking for a sense of depth
rather than thinness in working in
cities the this wall in Santiago de
Compostela in the rain which is an image
that we often think about and we think
about Alvaro Cesar's description of this
wonderful wall where he says it's a
monotonous and vibrant wall
finishing the square wavering between
nothing and magnetic presence when
opposes represents the question that we
often ask is how much do we as
architects need to do can we make a good
wall can we make something mute but
beautiful how how sometimes we need to
be in the background and sometimes we
need to make architecture that's in the
foreground and looking at cities we
think about the skin of cities we think
about scale and rhythm and these are
four maps that we made of London of
Dublin of Milan and of Toulouse each one
ours walk in each of these four cities
and it was really these maps were really
trying to understand the geography of
these cities and the kind of layers and
grain and there is a history that one
moves through in an hour's walk in any
of these cities because of both
understanding a city is so much about
measures scales rhythm sound and silence
and Manuel de Sala Morales talks about
the skin of cities and that we as
architects need to somehow give cities
the attention of a detective who
scrutinizes the tiniest clues in its
wrinkles and that's something that we
enjoy thinking about Dublin is the city
that we've grown in
city which which we've had our practice
for over 30 years
it's a city where we've been stitching
and repairing large and enlarged and
small projects the historic core is
double of Dublin is very much related to
the European tradition of streets and
squares and I suppose because of this
continuing practice that we've been
engaged in over the years of stitching
and repairing so now that's ingrained in
our consciousness irrespective of the
kind of problem or or a set of
conditions that were given in this
competition which we won with a
collaborative group 91 to reinstate an
urban quarter in Dublin the project was
very much about addition and not
subtraction and that's probably part of
our philosophy is to think about to
think more about what can we bring what
can we add and how little or if nothing
do we need to subtract we've also been
involved in educational buildings at the
scale of primary and secondary and
university buildings this exploratory
project to provoke a discussion in the
university of dublin about the role of
the humanities in the university and
they used us as architects to try to
provoke a debate about what the role of
the humanities should be in the context
of the role of the sciences for instance
and we made this space between library
and an Arts Building and made a kind of
free space within which anything could
happen we were interested in the idea of
the view of the university as a place to
which you go to look after and attend to
knowledge that a university is not
necessarily about the consumption of
knowledge but there is a collective
endeavor of care where knowledge lives
and hopefully flourishes and so in a
sense we were thinking about a
university as
a kind of garden and so we made this
unreal exploratory project we just made
a series of of canapes and light scoops
to catch the Sun protect from the wind
and make a kind of space which might be
a work space or a place of public use
and when we were making the sections
they thought that these these scribbles
looked like notes like music notes and
we were reminded of the great
traditional Irish musician one of them
from County Clare in the West of Ireland
when talking about playing his tin
whistle said it's not just the notes
that matter but it's the space between
the notes and we liked this idea of
making space between things of of making
use of interstitial space between
existing structures to make this kind of
semi endorse any outdoor world which
might allow free space allow the world
of the humanities to to happen and in
contrast we've also been working in
university building in the West of
Ireland in Limerick University where
we're making a medical school and
student accommodation we're not showing
this this evening before we are showing
is a house that we did for the president
of this university in in Limerick and
we're operating here in a campus which
is in the middle of the Irish Lions Gate
landscape just outside the city of
Limerick and these this image shows the
familiar ruined tower houses and castles
which sit in the space of the Irish
landscape like silent ghosts and actors
from the past and there's something
really poignant about the way that these
buildings sit hard in the landscape not
really
enclosing much territory around them but
somehow sitting hard on the ground and
having a sense of of presence both in
terms of the immediate surroundings and
in terms of the bigger horizon
and we were working in the North Campus
where there's a loose agricultural field
patterns in contrast with the more
orthogonal grid of the original part of
the University which occupies the
grounds of a classical stage house and
so we were working with the more let's
say primal and Irish tradition of the of
these towers and ruins and trying to
stake out territory in a way which in
some way was evocative of these kinds of
buildings carving and sculpting the
house too deep to make a sense of a
vertical stratification as and as I say
to finding a way of sitting that the
house in the landscape which would be
reminiscent of these buildings it's a
three-story house very simple modest
kind of project in many ways family
quarters to the north and the more
public functions facing the south over
the river shannon a loose form which
somehow adjusts itself to the
surroundings and again engaging with the
tradition of irish interiors using
limestone floors and the familiar
welcoming hearth at the entrance hallway
to the house and making raised terraces
overlooking the river making lofts for
the president's library overlooking the
grand dining room and I suppose using
the tradition of chunky timber furniture
which we find one finds in many
traditional Irish houses of the middle
size and somehow making windows and deep
walls which engage with the the
landscape both in terms of its immediacy
and it's bigger horizon and using
traditional techniques of building of
lime render limestone sills and timber
windows organic materials which adjust
and unchanged with the climate and
probably in contrast with the the more
stoic or heroic presence of these towers
and castles in Ireland is the tradition
of a much more modest way of occupying
ground and occupying landscape where
farm buildings and more modest housing
somehow merge with the the hedgerows and
the field patterns and and hug the
ground for shelter and that tradition is
one that we've used in the making of
schools where we hug the ground also for
shelter and stitch into existing corpses
of trees and make courtyards for
protection and make for ground or
entrance spaces which frame the sky and
frame the bigger horizon and the small
project is a little conference center
exploratory project again a competition
for a group of doctors again in County
Cork on the edge of a market town at one
street more or less kind of market town
and these doctors wanted to make a
building which in some way would allow
them to gather come together as a
collective practice setting up a new
model for the practice of of Medicine in
Ireland and we were using this modest
way of occupying ground of using walls
and berms and and hedgerows to to make
the territory media territory of the of
the building to protect from from wind
and using traditional elements like the
hearts as a kind of anchor to center to
make a center to the collaborative
exchange that would happen within this
building and again working the roof in
terms of how one would make a
collaborative space a large-scale kind
of workshop and I suppose it's a team
that we work with quite a bit is this
thing of working ground and working roof
and making that space in between the two
and we in this project are very again in
a very simple level we tried it was the
idea was that it would be a temporary
building that it will be cheap
that it will be prototypical and there
it will be exemplary and we looked at
how we could make a building sit lightly
on the ground with no foundations and
using merrill floor and hempcrete cement
free walls so again I suppose it's it's
it's somehow trying to refresh a
tradition which we which we which we
respect and using small-scale building
components which could be lifted by two
men to make the the roof scape and in a
way I suppose this project was
questioning and dealing with the
economic problems in Ireland the fact
that the construction industry has
changed completely and that new models
need to be developed in terms of how one
makes buildings more in in in terms of
the small scale grouping being able to
operate in a much more relaxed way to
make exemplary projects and combine
low-tech technology with with common
sense in terms of making a building
which would have a rudimentary feel but
in a sense would make the kind of
workshop space that these people were
looking for in terms of making a space
of collaboration and experimentation of
new ideas for them so this building
hovers somewhere between the kind of
industrial shed and the workshop and we
use this as as something to build on in
a recent competition we did for a small
art center in Tullamore in the Midlands
and this building occupies the canal
which was once the frontage of the canal
which was once once an industrial
thoroughfare and so we took many of the
ideas of the previous project to try to
develop a very economical way of making
an art center which would be a place of
work a place of exhibition a place of
theater but most of all the places of
joy and pleasure which would draw a
community together the
the Nobel prize-winning Mexican poet
Octavio Paz in his yeah thanks in his
uses of traditions si for their Luis
barragán book says and I quote to be
truly modern we must first come to terms
with our tradition as we have said this
evening we have been building for 30
years or so in Dublin and this aerial
view of Dublin shows the parks as a
rooms public spaces where you are more
conscious of the void and less conscious
of the object the 18th century grain and
rhythm form type of cliff walls they
have repetition not sameness they have
richness not complexity in our studies
50 to 70 percent of these walls are
solid if you note the chimneys what's
amazing about the chimneys as part of
the streetscape the chimney pots express
the individual rooms within that and
form part of the tiny air shafts into
these individual spaces traditionally in
Dublin special buildings are made out of
stone ordinary buildings are made out of
brick when we made our Department of
Finance we decided to use limestone
besides this building project that we
did is a pocket park which is a Huguenot
Cemetery and our project 20 70 70 feet
of a city street we made a simple
rectangular plan which allows the Sun to
penetrate all the elevations and allows
a 360 degree view of Dublin from within
the building is set in the context of
the city with the tonnage of limestone
cantilevering 3 metres 9 foot forming
part of the new geography of Dublin we
used a pale grey limestone with a sanded
finish we also used a dark grey Kilkenny
limestone and we burnt the surface of
the of the limestone releasing the the
under layers
we brought American bronze across the
Atlantic to form a screen into the
threshold essentially the project is
about officers but what we did was that
we took the only main as possible space
for us was the staircase and we made a
four-story main room a four-story space
hovering over the city
we made the awareness of where you are
the place that anchors you as part of
your movement up through the staircase
reminding you especially the civil
servants who work within the building
that the relationship of their work and
their intensity is to the city of Dublin
sorry I just go back the cloister what
we did actually in this in this
particular part of the Department of
Finance was to organize the circulation
to the edge to form a type of cloister
which meant that you had perimeter
circulation wrapping the city around the
edge of the building it meant that each
worker had a deep framed view and
remembering that you're part of the city
we love this lacquered screen by the
architect Gray interpreting the solid
and void so when we were studying the
elevations of the project we were using
this as a type of touchstone we were
also fascinated by this amazing project
in Stockholm by Peter cell Singh where
he used these elemental stone walls so
we made a deep stone and glass screen a
vertical weave of stone and glass where
a person can stand into the depth of the
wall and experience its depth this is an
image of the two cities Milan on the
right-hand side and Dublin Dublin shows
a city surrounded with the
infrastructure of canals were also
fascinated by the issue of time there's
something that was built 300 years ago
as a means of transport to connect parts
of the country has now become a place of
pleasure and when we were invited to
be part of competition in the city of
Milan we were struck by Lewis mum for
its words in the his book the city in
history he talks about a friar bond
vason in a book that was written in 1288
and he reported in the marvels of the
city of Milan that they were already
this is back in twelve eighty eight in
the thirteenth century there were
already two hundred thousand people in
that city and it's dependent area and
all the figures support a description of
a gigantic urban formation that had
already in its exuberance passed beyond
its medieval scale Richard Sennett in
his flesh and stone describes the
contemporary city as the body moves
passively desensitized in space to
destination set in a fragmented and
continuous urban geography
he says the road engineer and the TV
director conspire to create what could
be called freedom from resistance making
us separate from place and what we would
argue is that the role of the architect
is to claim back place not to be
desensitized but to be part of it this
image is one of Milan it's showing our
site of the project which is half an
hour south of the the Duomo in a
position just outside the Spanish the
Spanish walls Shelley referred to Manuel
de Soto Morales as describing the role
of architect has been type of detective
where you find clues in the wrinkles of
city and for us when we began looking at
the city again we're looking at these
finds and being reminded of how
wonderful and how powerful the Galleria
has a discovered a rediscovered treasure
for us in Milan or the roof of the Duomo
that stone man-made mountain in the
middle of that city for us this is a
terrific interpretive model made by one
of our students in the academia
maurizio which shows this kind of
hovering stone island in the middle of
Milan we also love Milan because it has
a city floor with a which is carpeted by
stone which is surrounded by various
asari it's a city of wonderful stone
this is a one we discovered to our great
delight a stone called Chapel and the
marvelous thing about Chapel is that
when it's used on buildings it's used
with absolutely the tiniest joint so it
merges to become a continuous surface
it's also a city layered with privacy
its restrained it has in secret interior
worlds this is an image of a fantastic
medieval building in the centre just
near the Duomo called el buro Leto and
what we loved about this building was
its continuous and repeated structure
but also that it was a place of exchange
and when we were studying the the
competition brief we also felt that
there was a component in a university
that is also is a place of exchange of
ideas so in 2001 we were one of 10 firms
that was invited to participate in this
competition in Milan we came to the city
with sketches in our pockets looking for
a strategy and looking for a grain that
would be appropriate the site is
embedded just outside the Spanish walls
part of the Bocconi University the site
here outlined in red on a noisy tram
street moving into the open weave of the
university complex itself and we looked
at spaces below ground because in the
year in the competition they asked for
50% of the accommodation to be below
ground which was the conference
facilities and the other percentage to
be above ground and we looked at spaces
below ground like obviously like the
beautiful Salk Institute and the sunken
churches in Ethiopia
the brief excuse me the brief required
offices for a thousand professors and
facilities for another 2,000 people
which would be as I said in conference
facilities below ground our strategy was
to hold these two worlds apart - to let
the space of the city enter in between
so in this interpretation here we raised
this as the representation of the
offices and the corrupted ground floor
beneath the master architect and teacher
Alexandre de la SOTA in one of his
seemingly absurd Maxim's says about
architecture and I quote that it is
about achieving as much nothing as
possible as architects we understand
this nothing to mean the space between
the space between city and streets
between inside and outside between
ground and sky the space where light and
air and volume are held it's the space
in which we stand as human beings
materials on the other hand are the
opposite to nothing we are interested in
making something out of nothing we are
interested in space volume and place we
were interested in transparency which is
layers of nothing illusion and effect so
we begin our struggle to interpret the
project within these structure of Milan
and within the the organization of the
the building fascinated by the surfaces
of the city we bring a stone carpet
right through the project which moves
into the campus we place the main
auditorium on the cusp between the
university and the main thoroughfare of
the city we delay the entrance to the
central point you arrive and drop down 5
meters that's 15 feet below street level
at this point or you move through as a
student or you rise up in this
particular point the place where the
thousand professors arrived and
move vertically from from their position
we also make a small Street connection
into the into the campus and we bring
students down to the lower level in the
in the plan excuse me we interpreted the
thousand offices as a raised matrix with
all the Attic hovering a box above the
city allowing light to penetrate below
so this is a working model where we're
studying the the grain the site was a
hundred and fifty meters long and
approximately eighty meters here and we
worked on a social structure of dividing
the thousand officers into bars of space
which acted like an abacus so this plan
is really describing the exes being the
voids the sketches being the solids of
the officers but setting up the grain
every 75 feet that we would set a
structural system that allowed for
socializing in the grain of the building
and here the sketch looking at the
soffits of the building undulating and
carving and bringing the space of the
city and excuse me down down below the
next important issue for us was how to
find a structure that would support that
architectural idea of separating the
ground and the hovering offices above so
this section drawing is really an
important moment in our design where
we're actually saying that we will
position the structure at roof level and
hang the offices from here so in this
section you have the structure
positioned at the roof level these
arrows representing the office layers
which are hung from above and that
liberates the space between the city
moving through and the carving into the
earth at this point just in terms of the
plan of the competition the air at the
officers sometimes double-loaded
corridors sometimes single ordered the
X's with the carving space allowing
light below and the long section showing
the alemana malya the the large space
set to the to the city the short section
and this three-dimensional perspective
visualizing the relationship between the
city as you move and move across the the
plan to connect students ramping down
the five meters the nine meters down to
the lower level the officers being hung
above and their soft words forming that
space that in between space the issue
then of a representation or finding a
language within an Milan close to our
site is this a fantastic project by the
architect Moretti and what for us was
really important was the fact of the
strength of expression in this project
in terms of Moretti's form protruding
like a great snout and for us this
carving of the section and finding a way
of overlapping and the expression of the
officers and the type of periscope
relationship with the Alemannia that
would reach up from being buried deep
into the city but also lifting its
ventilation kind of shafts into the city
form this is a misty foggy day in Milan
that has no river it sometimes has this
incredible atmosphere you don't know
exactly what time of day if this is a
the kind of nondescript corner of for
that for the competition and this is
setting our project in a pencil drawing
into the location and night view viewing
this kind of lantern position of the
Alemannia relative to the city and the
carved this is a model that wonders to
five hundred and reality where we're
pushing and pulling and carving into the
earth to allow that connection down to
the ground using the Alemannia like a
type of Boulder on the corner and using
the library as a type of crust or shield
to the to the to the edges of the site
and building off the little bars of
officers to form these kind of deep
quartz shading and allowing a controlled
light to enter below for us the
interesting thing about this space for
this here which is the 66 foot
cantilever of the Alemannia it's in two
parts for 600 people and 400 people the
street the city level is at this
there's five meters below fifteen feet
below is the entrance for the Iowa
Mannie so we were very lucky we were we
won this competition and we began
through obviously making the drawings
and tendering to begin to make the
project and talk about architecture as
the new geography it is incredible to
carve into a city floor to go down and
below the water table level to begin
this mammoth task of actually carving
the project into the surfaces of the
city so in this point here we are at
down below water table level we're
beginning the structure of the of the of
the building below and for us the the
issue this on the left hand side is a
photograph of the limestone in the burn
of the West in the West of Ireland and
what's amazing about the burn is that
the limestone over a eons of time has
been carved and crushed by the process
of its relationship to water and
sulfuric acid forming with this
combination and when we were doing the
competition this this modest paper a
card model is really trying to describe
that relationship of carving and pushing
and pulling that an intermediate world
between sky and and ground and we just
wanted to to share with you this evening
this fantastic image for us of a granite
boulder tossed by the Atlantic Ocean all
its corners rubbed off because it's
thrown and pushed and pulled so nothing
remains except the circle embedded
thrown by the sea onto this limestone
and it's something that I suppose we
will be discussing with our students
over the next number of weeks this
semester this issue of time and material
and the relationship between the
characteristics of physics of
materiality within architecture
so we began digging into the milanese
earth the great feat of the the
structure below and we have the 75 foot
apart
diaphragm walls with 11-foot twin spaces
which form these corridors so the
structure marches South down over the
site this becomes this amazing for us
this setting up of the measure forming a
type of social infrastructure the roof
beams then are positioned high up on the
structure from which the offices are
hung with the metal waiting to receive
the the offices laid in for us I suppose
architecture is the art of structuring
space for us structuring space is a
process of defining limits and
liberating boundaries when we show this
image of the the scaffolding for the
support of the weight of the cantilever
that's going to come what fascinates us
is the idea of translating an idea into
fact but also translating the weight of
wet concrete which will rest on this
supporting surface which will cure which
will become hard and will become the the
cantilever so here is the drying
concrete which forms the relationship
with the city back only then when we
chose the chapel stone for the building
the university bought the chapel
sorry bought the chapel quarry which for
us was fantastic because they actually
bought the mountain and when we went
there we were shocked because the
sloping surface of the mountain was
incredibly like the proposal we had for
the owl Romania it was like as if there
was a one-to-one model of the project
north in the mountains well was also
amazing for us was that the carving I
don't know what is like here in the
United States but the way they carved in
Italian quarries is that they quarry
deep into the mountain they cut the 27
foot by 27 foot by 27 foot they carve
out these cubes and they make these
incredible cathedral spaces with
which you can penetrate but also you
have fantastic ventilation and like
cathedral-like spaces and they leave
just enough mountain they take out as
much as they can leaving just enough
mountain to stand up these drawings for
us the top one is about lightness in
terms of the the structure of the
building and the lower drawing is about
weight Shelley talked earlier on about
the weight of gravity this is the
22-metre a cantilever hovering over the
over the city we did the long section
where each of the offices for the
professor's each has a glass screen
which represents their individuality
these are the pencil drawings during the
course of the competition describing the
internal world of the glass for the
officers and the crust for the external
relationship to city you're looking up
here at the crystal shards of the
lapping glass this is the chapel and the
outer crust of the building then the
building becomes embedded quietly into
the city context becoming as we say part
of the new geography am of milan we made
stone cliffs we made transparent
boundaries we carved deep caves and
quoting calm like the light in the
pantheon where you can feel the cut we
arrived under the suspended structure we
ramp down to the deep into the earth
we have staircases which lead up to the
sky we have places of public gathering
we have a 75 meter structure I mean this
is the consequence of the 75 meter
structure a certain 75 feet structure 75
meters it would have been better
we have the street level which is here
we have the minus 5 to 15 feet below and
then 9 metres below which is 27 feet
below ground level so you get this
social interaction which for us was a
fantastic consequence of the of the
structure we also have this issue of
interconnecting transparency and light
you can feel the force of gravity the
diagonal cuffs and as we move deeper
into the earth we change from the chapel
and we used a fantastic material called
Bianca Lhasa it's a type of white marble
the interior then becomes was once
described very beautifully for us like
an oyster shell
the interior of the what we call the
boulder or the interior of the owl a--
has three light scoops and it's the only
if you like interior cocoon space and in
the project we lined this with a pietre
siena stone and what's interesting for
us this is a model we made which is at a
in reality a scale of one is to 200
where you see the 600 and the 400 and
the 600 seat spaces occurs in in a
contours and when we go back to the
quarry and they in the mountains what's
interesting is that you see these kind
of shards of cosh in our one-to-one
model if you like in the in the northern
hills the hole for the thousand people
has natural daylight and the interesting
thing for us architectural II is that
this space underneath the viola has a
primal sense you're looking at it on a
wet night like last night here in in New
Haven you have the the wet you're on
you're standing on street level you're
looking into the to the space and
there's something about this space that
makes people want to dance they do
things in it that they don't normally do
there's something about it here which is
economists having a party and getting if
you like performers to
you perform with the space bearing down
above them and there's just some words
from Apple asthma that that's from the
his book the thinking hand where he
describes the ethical task of
architecture and art is so important in
a world where everything is becoming
similar in significance and of
insignificant and of no consequence they
have to maintain differences of meaning
and in particular the criteria of
sensuous extensional and existential
quality it remains the possibility a
responsibility of the artist and the
architect to defend the enigma of life
and the eroticism of the life world just
in relation to the 75 metres ban in the
on the jury in Milan was architect
engineer mangiarotti and there was a big
argument about whether our structure
would stand up or not and he told us we
had no courage that we should go to
minimum a 40 meter span that we were
young and that we should have more
courage so anyway that was kind of
encouraging in we having done the Milan
project we got on a shortlist for the
School of Economics in Toulouse and
luckily won this competition in a way
this kind of map sort of broken heart
map and suppose maybe displays to
students what we keep harping on about
how one maps places and how maps somehow
describe an atmosphere and I suppose how
we as architects these kind of maps
remind us that we as architects if we
map places in a you know an imaginative
way we can reinvent them and reread
places and find a way in to making
intervention
any places and Toulouse is the opposite
of Milan it's a very picturesque very
beautiful city was a big river the Quran
we moved to love Milan but Milan was
robust and gray and hard and defensive
and quite hard to penetrate and yet has
some of the most beautiful spaces and
buildings for us in Europe and Toulouse
was almost sweet by comparison this and
and the site we were about to work and
was part of the historic medieval core
or on the edge of the historical
medieval core of this red brick this red
brick city and so while working in Milan
somehow the tradition of the Italian
City and Milan being a kind of the part
of Milan we were working in was quite a
rational City and so it was almost
familiar to us in the sense of ways of
making city or ways of making grids in
cities but this city was of toulouse was
so organic and strange in many ways and
new to us with these kind of buttresses
and these strange towers and facades for
instance this this sorry thank you this
this element here this is not a tower
this is the facade of a church which is
about 15 meters wide so you look at
something that you think is a tower and
you discover it's a wall so it has it
was it had this whole other kind of
series of surprises for us and it
Toulouse consists of something like
thirty hidden towers within hidden
courtyards where the merchants lived
deep in the urban blocks and receded to
the rear of these dense blocks for
privacy and solitude and there was this
fantastic series of experiences of the
way that these courtyards frame framed
the sky
like a window to the sky when sorry when
we visited this remarkable space of the
Jacobin Church in Toulouse I suppose
there are moments when you you you think
really about what the nature of
architecture is or should be and moments
like visiting this church make us think
about the fact that the the nature of
music is described as being
inexpressible except through sound the
nature of music and spaces like this
make us feel that the nature of
architecture could be described as being
inexpressible except through space and
this space touches some unconscious
memory reminding us that architecture
has a public role and but its effects
are also felt in some private sphere of
memory and this is the the church which
we the the cloister of which we started
out with is in the is attached to this
church so when we visited our site it
was it's a series of layers and strata
from the the layer of the the canal
water of the toe paths the retaining
wall to the street the medieval wall and
the walls of the city it's at a junction
between the middie canal and the Garron
River and I suppose we felt the
gravitational pull of the of the of the
city on the site that somehow there was
a need to make something which would
reach outwards and in a sense this
sketch describes the starting point or
the searching for the idea that while in
Milan we buried all the conference rooms
in Toulouse we felt a need to bring all
the public rooms up out of up I suppose
high in the space to be able to view the
city and so this idea was the idea the
sketch expresses that in the background
would be the research offices of the
professors and through this kind of
monumental wall that we could make
windows
to the city animal sketches always
describe what we try to talk to students
about today and from now on and always
is that at the beginning of a project
your search is is a combination of
precision and randomness it's a
combination of not knowing what to do
and and having some idea of what you
want to do and it's a combination of the
rationale and the sort of emotional so
these sketches describe again this thing
of trying to see how the orange which
are the public rooms could be locators
in a way where they the more at the more
background spaces could could engage
with these rooms but but what could
somehow you pass these rooms to the to
the world of the city beyond so our site
is in this pivotal space it's a point
where the University site reaches down
and somehow occupies this point this
proud where the the branch of the media
canal connects with the Kuran River in a
sense the the geometry of the site and
the the nature of the of the city meant
that we made this kind of collage in a
way of the elements that we found in the
city of these buttress walls which are
in fact fire escapes tears of sky
cloisters and colonnades and courtyards
and all so that we could deal with the
climate of Toulouse and if we could make
spaces which were actually protected
from wind and rain but still external
and so we made the the public room of
the of the university is a central
courtyard it's actually the foyer and
the entrance hall but it's outside even
though it's protected from wind and rain
and so the building kind of inhales and
exhales and allows the world of the city
to spiral around its edges and we were
always in the project trying to make
these choreographed framed views of the
city beyond be it from terraces or
internal rooms or conference rooms and
then looking at the scale of the the
building in in the
this edge where the the medieval old
city
finishes and the new city begins so
we're on the side of an existing
medieval wall in the company of a
beautiful Roma Romanesque Church and
adjacent to a very active public square
and in this image at night we see the
the buttress of the Romanesque Church
and the forecourt to our building where
we've made this element which we call
the sky cloister of which it was to do
with making a promenade from the
president's office across two conference
rooms and within the building there's a
whole way of circulating externally as
well as internally and the the
introductory space is a 4-quart space
which frames the sky in the way the
money of the portraits in Toulouse
framed the sky so this main ramp takes
you into the heart of the building which
is a is protected from wind and rain but
is actually an external space and again
this comes from the spaces that we
visited in Toulouse where you get these
grand staircases but they're gators
they're not internal and there's
something lovely about the way that the
wind moves through these spaces in the
summertime and yet they're usable and
protected in the wintertime so just
looking at the layers and the strata and
the building up of of this dissection to
make I suppose what is the the social
heart of the of this university which is
protected from the elements but somehow
always relates to the city beyond this
is what we call the window between one
conference room and the other and these
terraces and bridges somehow occupy the
space of these deep window reveals
because we used the brick edges as fire
escape stairs we're able to deal with
with with that issue of safety and
escape and so all the circulation the
public important circulation is very
open and very free and these were
studies we had to do to prove to the
client and to the authorities that that
external internal -
places would work in terms of wind and
in terms of control of climate and all
of the elevations of this building are
mapped and worked in terms of light and
shade in terms of solid to void ratio
and in terms of dealing with the climate
and I suppose this sketch just shows
this sense of making an internal
landscape and this wish to choreograph
the connections to the to the different
to the various landmarks in the city
beyond and again the section which shows
the sky cloister and the entrance to the
building and this merging and blurring
of boundaries between spaces which are
internal and spaces which are external
and as well we we do think about
landscape the landscape of the city
becoming the interior landscape of the
of the world of the university within
this gentle ramp takes you up to - the
entrance foyer with bridges and terraces
which overlook this space so this is the
social heart of the of the building and
their study models the crude study
models I suppose is showing the way that
we work using technology but also
continually checking scales and the
qualities of space with these models and
looking at the technology of the making
of this building in brick and how we
make some we work as both thinking both
from the very particular detail of the
how we make a building in terms of the
actual material we're using but also how
the building sits in the landscape of
the city so we're continually moving
between scales thinking at both scales
concurrently and we feel that this is
this is important for us in the way that
we work to get a sense of connectivity
in terms of the language of making as
well as the the overall language of form
in the city and we discovered just
outside to lose this amazing
brick factory where they tell us they
make bricks in exactly the same way as
the Romans did but they used the same
size molds and the same size brick and
it was like a bakery it's like a brick
bakery where you could get hollow bricks
or ground bricks or square bricks or
whatever brick you wanted and it was
just amazing kind of place and and so
we'll be using this this ancient
material in a contemporary way in this
building in Toulouse we're finishing
with with with a project and which is at
a very early stage which is again making
a piece of city and at the same scale as
as Bocconi and we use this chile de
image as a way of describing one of our
starting points in terms of how one
could think about carving the urban
block but also I suppose in terms of a
quote by Laurent bouton who was one of
the competitors in for the Bocconi
project and he in in a text where he
talks about the architecture of spare
fen he uses a beautiful term where he
says architecture is a machine for
slowing time down and in our current
world that seems like a challenging idea
and so we thought about making this new
piece of City which is about 50,000
square meters by thinking about it as a
new piece of geography by thinking about
and making what is a single-use brief
which is symptomatic of our time that
somehow we're asked to make a piece of
City which is of this scale with only
one use with no rich mix of of a variety
of uses and so we have to find the space
that was missing to find the component
of the project which was missing which
is effectively the making of a public
space that would bring the workers
within this building together and so we
thought about carving the block in terms
of a way of taking
Souths life deep into the block and used
the cholita image as a kind of starting
point and thought about ways of how the
carving of the the track of the the
sunlight and this block would make the
public space which would somehow make
space where people would feel like
coming together and that we would make a
series of trapped landscapes and Gardens
for each hood and connect these blocks
and that that would somehow tell the
worker the time of day on the season and
simple things that that we need as
architects are supposed to think about
how can we make places of work
pleasurable or where people are
continually aware of of weather of time
of day of the seasons and we mapped this
carving of the block scientifically in
terms of taking South lies deep into an
east-west block and how that might make
a place where people might want to to
come and the the staircase I suppose is
a continuing preoccupation of ours and
how how the staircase is such a natural
place of gathering when one thinks of
I'm nearly finished
when one thinks of the classic hill town
how important the staircases and so
these study models in for us in making
this this new project and we just want
to I suppose conclude since we're
getting the message or the hint that
we're not making the case that the that
the traditional European city is the
only modern model for a new urbanism it
just happens that we've been working
generally speaking in sites embedded
within existing urban structures but we
are making the case that in developing a
new language for the making of new
places that we remember that
architecture is the protector of
humanity and together with speed and
time fast architecture can slow time
down and memory conscious and
unconscious is one of the components of
architecture our cities are sometimes a
collection of dislocated elements
truncated episodes heaps of objects
lacking visual coherence or apparent
meaning we have to engage in the
structuring of spaces not in the
abstract mode of master planning systems
and networks but in the construction of
a new geography with a human dimension
thank you thank you
thank you for a very beautiful talk
think everyone is probably slightly in
awe your command of language of built
and verbal so what we appreciate that
very much
I'm sure there are some questions in the
audience for you I hope there are
they thank you very much for a wonderful
talk and a very beautiful portfolio of
work one of the things I found really
interesting about your talk was what
seemed to me to be a kind of tension
between two apparently contradictory
notions the one your emphasis on the
sensual visceral experience of buildings
and places through feelings of weight of
mass or through an emphasis on detailing
and on the other hand your use of maps
you made extensive use of and you called
attention to this of maps of aerial
photos of satellite views and site plans
which one might associate with a more
abstracted view of the environment so
I'm just wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about how mapping
actually figures into your design
process I can certainly understand how
section views figure into your design
process but I'd like to hear a little
bit more about the maps um it's the
lovely question thank you and what is
amazing about maps is that they're not
the if you like the property of an
airplane at 35,000 feet the interesting
thing about a map is that when you read
a map you're actually reading the ruins
of thoughts of other people that you
that you can it's amazing you can look
at a map and and read spaces so we don't
see them as you know app they're
actually I find it interesting that
you've separated them for us the mapping
is the sensual description if you look
at Venice and you see you know why would
you build a city on mud why would you do
it and you you read the history of the
relationship between the landscape and
the mud and the power that that mapping
is is the if you like the app it's the
the hovering view of the sense
nature of history mapping is the the
scale what we find interesting in terms
of teaching and they'll be more and more
convinced about it the older we get is
that you you you have to be both
hovering like an eagle and swimming like
a fish of their the kind of wrong kind
of metaphors to use but that you're in
the water in Venice and you're seeing it
as a dis amazing you know for an
architect to read the pattern of city
like in the early of drawings of
drawings of Dublin when you read even
the history of mapping itself is a
wonderful thing to study because it's
also about our perception about how we
catalog edges so I think I don't think
they're actually so apart when we map
that's the larger organization of
humanity you map at the larger scale you
make it the more intimate so when we use
words like weaving you know we look at
the pattern of this wonderful orange
carpet that that there's a certain way
of the weft and weave or whatever the
words of weaving are but but mapping is
mapping is the footprint of humanity we
map out you can what's interesting you
can actually put together a jigsaw of
medieval you know like in Dublin you can
see the medieval the Viking remnants the
medieval the 18th century you can take
up this great jigsaw and it's the
technology and the kind of tectonics of
say 18th century George and Dublin
because of the brick ballast coming in
the ships because of the the structure
of the of the of the timber of the span
you can read there's a huge relationship
and mediate relationship between mapping
and the tectonic of the time the
structure and the ambition the great
boulevards you know you can see the king
saying oh I want the road engineer when
a red map a red line I think they're
like they're like em they're like pieces
of a symphony you you
I don't read music but somebody who can
opens a Beethoven and knows exactly you
open a map as an architect in you know
there are the old kings there you know
that not the relationship between making
mapping is us you know the mapping
google is amazing now i think the the
problem now is that there was a time
you'd fly too
you know as seville and you'd wake up
and there from arriving in the dark and
you can feel it make good and the googly
go gone the van and you go in there you
know turn off the google sometimes you
know no we need the map we need you
refer to space between the notes as you
were designing your different pieces
did you ever contemplate how those the
spacer is gonna get filled when you're
done
well we're actually always trying to
make spaces that don't get filled I'm
not sure we've ever really quite managed
stuff but we're really interested in the
idea I suppose this Valtra benjamin's
idea of open ends that one can make an
architecture that doesn't feel fully
finished and that one can make spaces
where the unanticipated could happen I
think it's a really difficult thing to
do but it's something that we're we're
actually really interested in so in a
sense when we talk about the space
between the notes are at the alejandra
dollar so the idea of a place for what
is it for to do as much nothing as
possible that's a really challenging
kind of contradictory thing to say in
the sense that that's what we as
architects should do is as much nothing
as possible but it's true in many ways
that that to make space which is not
fully prescriptive which allows life to
enter in and where maybe the
unanticipated I think it's also the kind
of Zen the issue of the bowl and the
bowl that contains and then the the
space which is the useful space and that
really we would be you know if you come
out with a placard and say what's
happening with architecture is that it's
so object driven and we're saying no
there's there's the not the bowl it's
the void and that that that's really
what we're saying that be aware as we
talk to students as we talk to ourselves
and is that I that it's the void that is
the potential there was an interesting
exercise we did during the summer it was
a workshop in a small town and over very
school it was an architectural workshop
to try and connect to the public and one
of the groups was a group of kind of 14
and 15 year old boys who did not want to
be there
and not our no architectural training
and nothing like that and one of the
exercise we gave them we had brought
this little Russian and papier-mache
bowl and we asked him to draw it and
they'll join anyway no matter and then
we asked them to draw what's in double
the void you can imagine you know and
this kind of a what we call a Laurel and
Hardy moment you know kind of but I
think there is that issue of the huge
pressure on the object the architectural
object now and that it's all about the
vision and it's all about the the
product how can you buy or who do you
get to make an architectural product
that you know University can have or
whatever and that I suppose the work
that we try to do is more a curiosity of
kind of getting inside the thing to find
what it could be there's another
phenomenon which we talked about which
happens is that when buildings get up
and running it's like as if they have a
strength of their own they're kind of
muscular things and they don't want
another story or they don't want another
thing it's they have an amazing capacity
to become themselves as kind of
creatures you know that they they don't
want things to happen to them are they
there's a it's an amazing phenomenon
when a Shelley described the kind of
difference between say to lose as a city
organic to lose be organic and Milan
being rationalist ever a rational city
that the kind of muscular quality of the
Bocconi project kind of set itself up as
a big matric and kind of just wanted to
sit there and go it's an amazing kind of
phenomenon over the space between you're
asking about the void I suppose were
more interest in the the consequence of
need that essentially architects respond
to need and then space becomes part of
the project the creation of that project
the invention each project is an
invention
court reporter or references to
landscapes particularly compelling they
really emphasize something that acts a
dimension that too often is completely
excluded because a building is set off
categorically against it so also the
pictures that you showed from the
quarries to the caustic landscapes etc
like the score of passage of ice and
water and very long processes but that
makes me think that in various respects
your buildings possess qualities that
are very similar to these natural
conditions but what that does to the
building in its appearance is it makes
it very close to ruins because only in
ruins do you usually have all of these
sight lines open you can pass through in
different ways that nobody had
anticipated from below and from above
you get diagonal views the sky comes
through again all of the sudden so I'm
day I was very struck by that because
our just the other day came across by
chance a statement by marks Frisch the
Swiss writer who is a architect actually
it has an architecture degree and it
building etc and he at some point says
that it what a pity that most buildings
get finished because it is only when the
roof is not yet quite complete when
nobody has put in the windows that you
can certainly see from the cellar all
the way through to the sky again and
that puts the building into this vast
panorama of a time process that begins
it's not yet finished
it may get finished it will be changed
it will perhaps decay and therefore it
opens up all of these not fully
exhausted possibilities that most
buildings shut down closed off deny
in order to achieve their identity so
Khan was right because calm we had the
same experience and drew them that draw
to see the drawings of Kong of Roman
ruins is actually the experience not so
much only for the ruins but because of
what he turns them into the most obvious
inspiration at least on the surface when
a word in for the man there are some
books which never leave your side and
they the con books are I have say we
came late to come because we we grew up
as the caboose efn at assists one could
say we were completely taken and it's
not late but later than you know being
in college I suppose particularly in
relation to doing Toulouse we've found
gone back and back again to comment and
incant visited Toulouse and Albie
which is a fantastic City quite close to
Toulouse and made many drawings and
sketches of that so because it's it's
it's Italian magazine brick magazine
asked was recently do we like to use
brick I mean how do you answer a
question like that it's also amazing the
difference between using brick in Dublin
and and trying to use break in Toulouse
it's almost like it's a different
material because you have to find you
know you the the joint sizes are bigger
than mortar mix as bigger the scale of
the brick is different it's it's it's a
different material and you know say
and what's wonderful about tom is the
way he uses break in India or America
and it's and it's it's work that's
continually there but I suppose it's
also the fact that his writings are so
profoundly challenging questions always
I just want to thank a beautiful series
of projects and very very carefully done
it was really inspiring it's clear in
your work that there's a persistent
interest in breaking down a much larger
building into a smaller series of
objects and and you spoke eloquently
about the notes but there's space
between the notes and I guess one of the
things that I wondered about is is there
in any of your projects an interest in
in not building a single building in
other words is it ever on the table that
what you're actually going to set out to
build are are a series of buildings that
that create spaces between them the same
types of spaces that you're talking
about is that is that ever on the table
or do we do the projects become
essentially a very large building
because the demands of program and
client and air conditioning etc can you
speak can you speak to that issue as a
sort of planning strategy well I mean
there many projects that we haven't
shown which would have been a collection
of individual buildings and our projects
are not that big we've done one big
project which is the Milan project which
is 60,000 square meters and that that
was 10 times bigger than I think we've
ever done before and the building in
Toulouse is one sixth of that size but I
suppose it happens that the projects
were shown this evening were single-use
like a university building which works
with courtyards and maybe has a certain
singularity but and I suppose it it
probably relates to the nature of the
program the nature of the science the
nature of the idea and whether buildings
work by being separation like housing
for instance housing projects we've done
there are separate buildings there are
individual buildings or school projects
we've done four component parts are
separated but maybe it's because we find
sometimes there's there's we try to
always go straight to the core of a
project and sometimes the making of
individual elements expressive elements
and and and separating out a program
becomes very compositional exercise and
and we found that maybe that very often
it's it's it's quite interesting to see
what spaces can hold the component parts
of a project together but we are
building at the moment we're building a
School of Medicine in a in the campus
the same campus as there has been the
president near that we're building a
School of Medicine some student housing
and then were part of making the plaza
so that's also to do it funding in
university structures that you know that
certain pieces are built in in a certain
kind of sequence but then it's it's then
it becomes how do you make the space for
social gathering so you use the if you
like the boulders of the buildings to
play in the landscape so it depends on
on the size of the Commission in the
Bocconi project that was really they had
already full planning permission for a
previous project they weren't happy with
that they went internationally too
Brian find something but it was a city
part of a city block so there were other
competitors in that competition when
when that competition was decided and
there was an exhibition of all ten in
the gallery in an exhibition in the
Galleria you you saw the various other
competitors and what they had submitted
and some of them had done if you like a
objects within that but it's the
interesting thing I suppose in City
going back to the question on mapping is
that when you build in in in city in the
kind of established grain of European
city there tends to be a kind of a not
quite join the dots but you're within a
structure that's that's wonderful to be
part of a symphony so the the issue I
mean it is something that that I that I
personally find challenging is is the I
was recently in in Tampa in Florida and
realized that that that to the American
sensibility that the car is a jacket
it's not a machine that you get into in
a space and that it's a different sense
of space so I'm very conscious that I
don't understand really the American
word and city in the same way as I
understand it in European sense and that
may be the the projects that were do are
embedded in existing kind of containers
if you like where maybe there's another
issue which is to do with going back to
that Richard Sennett thing whether you
know his comment about that the modern
city is really has no resistance to you
can there's fluid and you you have no
resistance you have nothing to stop you
in a place so it's a kind of a
roundabout I supposed to do with the
scale of our projects you know if you
cut then the issue if you had thousands
and thousands of square meters to deal
with but it's something I suppose we
talk about is that one of the main
problems with master planning and large
scale is that sometimes it's not enough
and there's a single mind doing so big
we would argue like when we did we move
on that project
central Dublin in 1991 we had worked
with a group of like-minded architects
to create a group 91 and we had done
with Dublin City Council a project where
we divided a site up into eight kind of
slices and share them and that that city
is also we were talking today the Senate
also in his book the flesh and stone
quotes Aristotle and - to paraphrase
Aristotle excuse me is that him you know
cities are made up they're not just made
by Wantagh you have to have mix you have
to have difference and that may be if
the projects were much larger one of the
things that Shelley is a very outspoken
about is that really things should be
divided up and shared among groups of
architects so you get different
sensibilities and different grits rather
than the toothpaste version of you know
the big big project just being too big
for a single architectural firm to
handle it also is an issue scale and
materiality okay there's a question and
then Eduardo and then we will break it
up because we have to go on to the most
important part I'm very interested in
your attitude towards the images the
image of your buildings in your
discussion you talk about a haptic
qualities about us share lot of sections
the depth and talk about interiors a lot
and yet your facades for a better phrase
are incredibly well composed and quite
exquisite and the fact they win
competitions suggests that they have a
real power so you must walk about
there's a lot at least amongst ourselves
and I wonder how that fits within a lot
of the language you've been using
tonight about the more kind of haptic
qualities how do you engage with the
image of your buildings
well with the Bocconi project for
instance I think it took us I don't know
four months three months of struggling
to find not so much a facade but a
language and we continued I thought what
we found was the connection between the
interior and the exterior not form
follows function but that there's
something about the integrity of the
relationship between the interior and
the exterior that gives you the language
and when you haven't got it you know it
and when you start to get it you know
and in Bocconi it was by letting the
section become the language both in
terms of the shield we made to the
secondary street which was a series of
interlocking double-height spaces which
we just let happen and manipulated and
in the more expressive elevation on to
the alla Bellini was literally when we
took away the facade and just let the
section be the project in Toulouse it
was more difficult I think in many ways
because in a sense you could say we were
working with the picturesque and the
picturesque is tricky and but in the end
the the expression or the facade of
Toulouse came from deciding that we do
not want to make a building which
exposes itself to the Sun and as
hundreds of windows facing south and how
could we make a building which is loads
of offices but still feels solid so we
use the fire escape stairs to make
buttresses and we had 50% of us we had
it then because we could we could
somehow work that we had enough solid to
make a wall and then in working the wall
we were really thinking about brick and
we were right beside a medieval brick
wall so we had to
seriously we still have to make a
seriously good wall so we really worked
with how we could make that all do
things you know where it's it's it's
it's it's manipulated in terms of light
and shade and in terms of the depth and
shadow because we didn't want to make a
flat building because the light and
shade like in this building which is
wonderful the way that the manipulation
of the surface gives you the light and
shade so well they and thank you for you
I was afraid of the question you need to
ask me for some reason why I thought you
can ask me a really really hard question
this is hard too
but really that's why I had a hard
question for you but in in a sense it
it's it it comes out of that
interrogation of what it is the wall has
to do and energy think of the the
effects that I mean I really do believe
that the thing that we started out with
David leather Vera talks about which is
light and shade if you can get back to
the basics in terms of high maker a wall
in terms of light and shade well then
it's somehow different we we don't like
the word elevations anymore
in fact it we try to use the word
walking past us which suggests that it's
flat and that it's composed I mean it's
important and we work with them but if
you you have to come to it somehow it's
it's it's it's the really hardest
moment in a project so there is a
problem with if you like the modern
client and the ability to reproduce a
building too quickly before it's kind of
grown and that a client you know you can
do one of these kind of CG eyes and
they're really you know tell everything
and there's absolutely no mystery and no
moving along and no development I think
there is a that issue of the word
elevation I mean it comes from the
construction industry as it was elevated
you know that's in there were times when
you build scaffolding up and you only
had the drawings for that amount and
then you build it again they build that
amount and it was revealed so I think
the we just have to also be careful that
the facade oddness of of buildings the
kind of just the crust and not the thing
behind I mean it was interesting in the
process of the but of the pokorny
project that there were lots and lots of
drawings looking at everything no no
it's not there it's not nothing there so
I think we were just putting windows on
an office block which you could easily
have been you know you know what the
thousand offices it could easily have
been just thousand windows and yet
there's a translation that goes on from
need into form and it is more about the
function and the organization that
finally then when the the kind of
strength of that is strong enough to
stand on its own two feet it doesn't
have to have a